[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 c'est l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale et régionale tout de
suite les titres de ce jeudi 21 mars
saint quentin en yvelines réfléchit à
son plan paysage un outil pour penser
l'aménagement des douze communes de
l'agglomération de manière plus homogène
une réunion publique sur le sujet se
tenait hier est une plateforme
participative a ouvert pour recueillir
l'avis des habitants renault imagine l'
usine du futur à l'occasion de la 9ème
semaine de l'industrie le technocentre à
guyancourt a organisé une exposition sur
les modes de conception de demain une
filière de l'automobile qui représente
45 mille emplois dans les yvelines
et puis montigny le bretonneux accueille
ce week-end les journées international
d'aïkido deux jours d'événements dédiés
à cet art martial venu du japon des
maîtres de toute l'europe seront
également présents
invité de ce journal thomas à tessier du
club d'aïkido de montigny donner son
avis à saint quentin en yvelines sur le
paysage l'agglomération a lancé
récemment une plateforme participative
les habitants et usagers du territoire
peuvent s'y exprimer et proposer des
solutions pour leur environnement
l'objectif alimenter la réflexion sur le
plan paysage en cours d'élaboration
douze communes et des territoires
différents dont il faut désormais penser
l'aménagement de manière harmonieuse
pour y parvenir
saint-quentin-en-yvelines élabore son
plan paysage un outil pour répertorier
tous les éléments du paysage de
l'agglomération qu'il soit naturel
urbain ou agricole cette réflexion
servira ensuite dans l'élaboration des
futurs documents de la collectivité
comme le plan local d'urbanisme
intercommunal
on est en train de penser l'aménagement
de notre territoire pour demain plutôt
que de continuer un peu aménagés chacun
dans notre coin chacun je dirais dans sa
ville
eh bien ça va nous obliger à repenser
les choses de façon beaucoup plus
global puisque à l'échelle d'un
territoire la réflexion sur le plan
paysage débute par une phase de
diagnostic une étude menée par un
cabinet à laquelle sont associés les
saint quentinois mercredi 20 mars ils
étaient une vingtaine à participer à une
réunion publique d'information
l'occasion d'échanger sur leur vision du
paysage
ce qu'on aime bien quand même à ça quand
on sait qu'il ya quand même beaucoup d
espace arboré ce qu'on souhaiterait
c'est surtout éviter de minéralisée les
sols parce qu'il ya beaucoup de place
aujourd'hui qui sont malheureusement
plutôt garni de pavés plutôt que d'armes
on a un site historique patrimonial
sûrement pas qu'on aimerait beaucoup
conserver et compris son environnement
et ses paysages et d'autres sites
d'autres lieux d'autres square enfin il
ya beaucoup d'endroits intéressant à
sauvegarder à mettre en avant qu'on a un
passé historique qui est important avec
un point supplémentaire qui remonte au
moyen âge c'est à dire le lieu dit des
trois bornes où était rendu la justice
et qui se trouvent sur notre territoire
mais qui n'est pas indiqué ni valorisé
pour recueillir ses avis sur le paysage
saint quentin en yvelines a lancé une
plateforme participative les habitants
et usagers pourront exprimer ce qu'ils
souhaitent voir conserver améliorer ou
transformer un postant des photos et des
balades urbaines seront également
organisées dans différents lieux
remarquables du territoire et une fois
la stratégie élaboré un plan d'action
sur le paysage est prévue pour 2020 un
paysage qui va d'ailleurs évoluer
prochainement à maurepas la ville a reçu
le soutien financier de l'île de france
une subvention d'un million d'euros dans
le cadre du contrat d'aménagement
régional qui finance des projets en
matière d'équipement et des espaces
publics la subvention va se servir dans
le cadre de deux chantiers celui de la
rénovation du centre-ville de maurepas
hauteur de 430 3000 euros 5 166 mille
euros seront eux tourné pour la
réhabilitation et l'extension du groupe
scolaire de la géo en cette journée
nationale du coworking l'espace de
travail à partager stop and works a fêté
son premier anniversaire ce jeudi
il est implanté près de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines à montigny le
bretonneux
plus de 150 personnes dont de nombreux
collaborateurs ont fait le déplacement
pour cet évènement et pour échanger des
cartes de visite le directeur de la
structure dressant un premier bilan
après un an d'activité c'est au micro de
michael et demi d'euros premier bilan
très positif je dirais plutôt un pari
gagnant aujourd'hui le centre est aux
trois quarts plein les places se font de
plus en plus rares on a eu de très
nombreuses recommandations de nombreuses
personnes viennent visiter le centre
pour dans un futur très proche prendre
de nouveaux bureaux et des personnes
même de la région parisienne viennent ne
serait ce que pour réaliser du
télétravail dans l'actualité également
l'inquiétude des salariés de castorama
et brico dépôt le groupe britannique
dans saigne de bricolage kingfisher a
annoncé hier son mauvais bilan financier
conséquence 11 magasins vont fermer en
france dont 7 dans la région
francilienne est d'ici novembre 2020
dans les yvelines le brico dépôt de
flins sur seine est concerné ouvert en
2012 s'il en 2012 il baissera le rideau
dès l'automne 62 personnes travaillent
sur le site
le groupe la poste lui de son côté
annoncé une campagne de recrutement dans
le département cette année plus de 130
facteurs seront embauchés annonce la
direction 118 avait déjà signé un
contrat en cdi en 2018 les futurs
employés recrutés au niveau débutants
auront une formation de 15 jours dédiés
aux métiers de la distribution au
management de la santé et à la sécurité
au travail pour postuler les candidats
doivent se connecter sur le site
internet la poste recrutent
la 9e édition de la semaine de
l'industrie se poursuit dans toute la
france c'est jusqu'au 24 mars dans les
yvelines la filière automobile est bien
représentée avec 45 mille salariés et
plus de 150 entreprises notamment
renault et son technocentre à guyancourt
le site a organisé une exposition le
thème celle usine du futur découverte de
cette industrie 4.0 avec nicolas landry
un robot collaboratif pour transporter
des outils sur une chaîne de montage un
chariot élévateur fonctionnant seul ou
un drone programmé pour l'inventaire des
pièces bienvenue dans l' usine
automobile du futur développé depuis
2016 trois quarts de ces technologies
sont déployés dans les usines renault
objectif améliorer la performance
industrielle des sites de production
premier point c'est sur la sécurité
vous l'avez eue ici à plein
d'illustrations sur l'amélioration de la
sécurité sur la bière lioration de
l'avionneur deuxième point majeur sur la
qualité des produits que l'on délivre le
fait d'avoir une qualité maîtrisée sur
l'ensemble de notre production et enfin
le troisième point c'est notre
performance finalement financière pour
faire les produits les moins chers
possibles
ces technologies sont développées dans
les usines en collaborant avec des
entreprises
c'est le cas de ce robot collaboratif un
système de vision pour contrôler la
qualité des pièces ici on va venir voir
si les coutures sont bien placés
le contrôle après on va voir si à
l'instar de l'apport qu'on allait les
bons caractère qui sont sur les poignets
l'industrie 4.0 s'est aussi connecté les
collaborateurs entre suivre en temps
réel la production de la commande du
véhicule à la livraison ou encore tester
l'implantation de nouveaux outils grâce
à la réalité virtuelle
par exemple je veux voir si lilo pourra
être implanté on s'aperçoit ici que on
est limite
du poteau en béton de lusine donc
avec ceux ci on va pouvoir faire un
rapport voilà j'ai fait une mesure qui
me permet de savoir le positionnement je
vais avoir entre mavericks et l' usine à
terme le déploiement de ces technologies
se fera à l'échelle de l'alliance
renault nissan mitsubishi
prochain défi le développement de
l'utilisation des données et de
l'intelligence artificielle la direction
cette fois ci le forum peugeot à poissy
où une cérémonie était organisée à cette
semaine le deuxième prix de
l'entrepreneur a été remis en présence
de louis gallois le président du conseil
de surveillance de psa organisé par
grand paris seine et oise le prix
récompense des entrepreneurs et porteurs
de projets pour leur créativité
cette année six lauréats se partagent
une dotation globale de 31 mille euros
ce sera l'un des rendez vous à ne pas
manquer cette année dans le territoire
la dernière étape du tour de france
passera par les yvelines une dernière
étape au départ de rambouillet qui
traversera est notamment le sud yvelines
événement rendu possible grâce à un
partenariat signé entre le département
et les organisateurs de la grande boucle
les détails de michael et demi d'euros
le tour de france passera par les
yvelines au minimum jusqu'en 2023 les
organisateurs et le département signé
une convention en ce sens mercredi 20
mars
objectif préparer les jeux olympiques
2024 avec notamment à départ en 2023 du
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines toutes les
épreuves cyclistes
qu'elles soient à l'intérieur du
vélodrome ou à l'extérieur le bmx le vtt
le vélo sur route tout se tient dans les
yvelines il était donc pour une logique
de préparer ce très grand moment
on reverra pas les olympiques en france
avant des décennies
et donc
le département veut monter en puissance
pour les organisateurs ce partenariat
avec les yvelines marque une continuité
dans l'histoire du tour de france le
tour de france dès sa première édition
en 1903 et pas fait sur le territoire
des yvelines c'était la seine et oise à
l'époque
juste avant l'arrivée de la dernière
étape et c'est d'ailleurs le vainqueur
du tour de france du premier tour de
france maurice guérin qui avait gagné
cette étape là donc il ya un tas
d'histoires qui sont passés dans le
département en une échappée formidable
de bernard hinault avec son rival
hollandais götze tomek voilà jusqu'aux
dernières éditions pour cette première
collaboration dans ce partenariat
rambouillet a été retenue comme ville
départ de la dernière étape vers paris
le dimanche 28 juillet une première
depuis 2012 donc on attend bien sûr
beaucoup de monde 40000 spectateurs en
on va essayer de battre le record on
attend du tourisme on attend une image
rambouillet est déjà connu au niveau
international la dernière étape est une
des étapes les plus regardées du tour de
france donc voilà c'est l'image
l'identité de rambouillet qu'on ait
cette magnifique identité qu'on veut que
le monde entier connaît ça après
rambouillet le peloton devrait passer
par la vallée de chevreuse joueur jose à
ce but qu avant de quitter le
département à vélizy-villacoublay le
sport encore avec mon nouvel invité
thomas tessier bonsoir en sang vous êtes
le directeur technique de l'aïkido
montigny le bretonneux alors le club
organise samedi et dimanche les journées
international d'aïkido 7 au centre
sportif pierre de coubertin une petite
présentation de l'aïkido déjà avant de
présenter l'événement c'est un art
martial quelle est sa particularité par
rapport aux autres arts martiaux alors
l'aïkido est un art martial japonais qui
nous vient du maître fondateur morihei
ueshiba en aïkido naissent aussi deux
mots qui au premier abord vont pas
forcément ensemble c'est défensif les
kilos uniquement défensive accord et non
violents dans l'imaginaire collectif on
s'imagine que pour se défendre il faut
obligatoirement répondre à la violence
par la violence
l'aïkido propose une autre manière de
faire et cette manière là c'est de
chercher à s'harmoniser avec l'autre
donc le maître chiba le message du
maître c'est l'aïkido est amour alors
amoureux sens du respect de la personne
humaine donc arts martiaux c'est pas
qu'un sport ça va au delà il ya une
dimension peut-être spirituel aussi
c'est
c'est une ligne d'eau c'est une voix
l'aïkido qui vous accompagne au jour le
jour et qui vous aide à gérer tous types
de conflits tout type d'agressivité au
quotidien donc le principe au niveau
technique et au principe de l'aïkido
c'est de ne pas s'opposer à l'autre mais
plutôt de mettre son énergie avec celle
de l'autre vous l'avez dit c'est un art
qui nous vient du japon est ce que c'est
très développé en france c'est ce qu'il
ya de nombreux clubs d'aïkido laurier
environ 60000 pratiquants d'aïkido en
france c'est bien entendu bien moins
développé que le judo de par le fait
qu'il n'y a pas de compétition et kido
donc les kilos de ne passe pas à la
télévision a pas aujourd'hui un petit
peu voilà et puis je disais l'aïkido et
non-violents d'accord et je crois que
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui les acquis
deux cas soit un petit peu à part
puisque quand on regarde autour de soi
la violence est partout
enfin message d'importance à ce message
de non-violence à véhiculer ben c'est le
message essentiel de l'aïkido le maître
chiba a créé l'aïkido pour ça pour faire
en sorte que les hommes puissent vivre
en paix voilà quels que soient les
frontières quelle que soit leur pays
d'origine quelle que soit leur couleur
de peau
quel que soit leur âge voilà les kilos
est vraiment fait pour tout le monde
c'est vrai que dans le monde actuel
c'est un message que l'on a besoin
d'entendre alors à montigny le
bretonneux justement il ya combien
d'adhérents combien de pratiquants de
l'aïkido
alors cette année nous sommes 130
adhérents avec environ deux tiers
d'enfants et un tiers d'adultes
le club d'aïkido a été créée en 1981
d'accord jean-pierre fillot qui est
enseigné jusqu'en 2015 et je suis encore
aujourd'hui activement son enseignement
j'essaye demande mieux de transmettre ça
à montigny voilà depuis 2015 aux enfants
et aux abus la transmission c'est très
important où le fonds de m en maître de
pratique en pratiquant c'est une chose
primordiale
oui c'est essentiel c'est sa selle
puisque ce message qui est magnifique
message des kilos il faut qu'ils
perdurent dans le temps et donc il faut
que
du professeur à l'élève la transmission
se fasse et que l'élève qui devient
surtout aux professeurs puissent
enseigner à la fois la technique et
l'esprit de l'aïkido le maître chiba
voulu que l'esprit et la technique soit
mis ensemble comme deux faces d'une même
médaille
et vous le disiez le club de montigny
présent depuis les années 80 ça fait
aussi plusieurs années plusieurs fois
qu'il organise de telles journées
internationales
donc cette année ce sera la cinquième
édition des journées internationales la
première édition ayant eu lieu en 2005 à
l'initiative encore une fois de jean
pierre fillon donc moi je reprends
fièrement le flambeau
ce week-end donc avec deux nouvelles
journées internationales et c'est une
édition spéciale puisqu'elle permettra
de commémorer les 20 ans de la
disparition de m nokere un maître
d'aïkido qui était-il mettre nos quais
alors mettre nos quais c'est le premier
étranger à être allié étudié l'aïkido au
japon auprès du maître donc il était
élève à domicile ce qu'on appelle en
japonais uci déchire et pendant trois
années de 1955 à 58
il a suivi l'enseignement du maître à
raison de cinq heures d'entraînement par
jour voilà il ensuite il est rentré en
france et il a eu sept petites notions
là de transmettre les kilos à la fois en
france et donc dans toutes leurs pouces
été le précurseur en europe c'est le
pionnier français de l'aïkido le liquide
aux france est apparue dans les années
quarante sept avec un make up être qui
s'appelait m mochizuki dit voilà m en
hockey a pris avec m mochizuki puis avec
avec le maître tadashi ab et en 55 il eu
l'opportunité d'être invité par le
maître chiba donc voilà le maître mot
qui est pratiqué le judo il a tout mis
de côté pour vivre à fond cette aventure
et qui doit donc il ya aussi une autre
volonté pour cet événement et ça va de
pair avec ce message de non-violence et
l'union entre les pays à plusieurs
adhérents qui vont accueillir chez eux
ddd les dépendants des délégations
étrangères des des adhérents d'autres
pays qui viennent
il faut savoir que les cadeaux au départ
étaient réservés
exclusivement japonais puis est arrivée
la seconde guerre mondiale et le maître
chiba quand il a vu toute cette violence
la violence inouïe de cette guerre a
décidé d'ouvrir l'aïkido au monde et son
message à lui c'est de faire en sorte
que tous les peuples puissent se réunir
autour d'un même feu et ça n'a pas de
sens on aikido de parler de frontières
on considère tous les hommes comme une
seule famille est donc ce week end on
rend hommage à la fois maître chez ba
disparu il ya cinquante ans est à la
fois mettre nos quais disparu il ya 20
ans elles viendront douce et ses dégâts
de ces délégations de quel pays alors il
y aura cinq nations européennes
représenter la france bien évidemment
mais aussi la belgique l'angleterre
l'allemagne et la petite nouveauté cette
année c'est l'autriche avec la présence
de grands maîtres avec la présence ou et
de hauts gradés de très hauts gradés
même puisqu'il y aura des 7e dan
d'aïkido
pour vous donner une idée le plus haut
gradé en france et 8e dan
c'est christian tissier juste pour
terminer nous reste un peu moins d'une
minute quel est le programme des deux
jours ça se fait sous forme de stage
c'est ça voilà donc le stage et kido
c'est une rencontre
il va y avoir six heures de cours le
samedi
répartie sur deux la matinée
l'après-midi et quatre heures de cours
le dimanche
pareil deux heures le matin deux heures
l'après midi et chaque enseignant de
chaque pays va se succéder pour
transmettre ce qu'il a reçu qu'attendez
vous de ces journées quels sont les
objectifs pour ce week-end l'objectif
c'est de rendre hommage à m ok
l'objectif c'est d'être tous ensemble et
l'aïkido a vocation à créer des liens
avec les autres noms peu il faut
entretenir ses liens voir les recréer et
j'espère que ça va perdurer dans le
temps et qui organisera de nouvelles
jantes journée internationale et puis
même pu venir à rendre visite à nos amis
étrangers journée international d'aïkido
programme ce week end à montigny le
bretonneux samedi et dimanche c'est au
centre sportif pierre de coubertin merci
thomas tessier merci à vous et on
retrouve bien sûr toutes les
informations sur votre site internet le
site de l'aïkido montigny si vous êtes
montés à bord des skis bus aujourd'hui
vous avez peut être croisé des comédiens
déclamant des poèmes toute la journée
ils ont sillonné 50 ans
dans le cadre de la journée mondiale de
la poésie et du printemps des poètes est
la caméra daury lire 11 était présente
sur la ligne 400 une fait des
révolutions
déclamer des poèmes à l'arrière d'un bus
une idée originale pour susciter
l'intérêt des passagers de la ligne 400
une à destination ne mord pas ces
embuscades poétique se déroule dans le
cadre du printemps des poètes et sont
proposés par un collectif parisien
les profs d'histoire dans le bus ils ont
liberté totale soit collectif ou
individuel de dire des poèmes de les
chanter de l'écrit et de le hurler de
les murmures et à qui veut les entendre
et ils leur offrent chaque personne qui
écoute on leur offre un marque page sur
laquelle il ya des pommes des cris je
suis pas weight mais j'aime la poésie
des belles paroles comme on dit une
quinzaine de comédiens répartis en deux
groupes sont invités tout au long de la
journée sur plusieurs lignes du réseau
stibus le créateur écouta les propos
la première fois qu'on l'a fait j'étais
un petit peu à kate me disant comment
les clients vont recevoir 7
cette manifestation et ça s'est très
bien passé les conducteurs également les
conducteurs également apprécié parce que
ça les change c'est un petit peu d'avoir
de l'animation dans leur bus cette année
le printemps des poètes est placée sous
le signe de la beauté
un thème inspirant pour les comédiens
car le monde est beau le printemps est
bon le la vie belle
et notre but est de leur rappeler la
beauté de la vie pour que le ressorte du
bus avec un sourire et la joie de vivre
une performance sur la thématique de la
forêt les présenter ce samedi à la ferme
du mousseau d'elancourt par l'école de
danse c'est dans le cadre du festival
courants d'art mélange de danse et de
poésie
patrick jacques de dixmude et nicolas
d'andré il se promène au milieu de
l'exposition à l'ombre des forêts puis
se fige et se transforme en arbre voici
la forêt humaine imaginé par les élèves
de l'école de danse d'elancourt une
performance artistique et arborescentes
préparé dans le cadre du festival
courants d'art à la ferme du mousseau la
performance et à un moment on songe où
on se met en jeu avec des moments
d'improvisation justement faire pousser
créer des architectures d'arbres à
partir donc de cette de ce jeu avec le
bras et la main et le regard âgés de 9 à
11 ans et enfants se sont emparés de
l'univers forestier pour créer un poème
des mouvements le bruit des feuilles
accompagnés par les professionnels
cécile oumhani pour la poésie et gilles
verièpe pour la chorégraphie dans la
performance au fait on commence par
faire un parent marché dans on va dire
comme une forêt après on fait
on commence à faire un arbre thérèse
marie et nous a dit déjà sur la vie des
idées d'al ayyat des propose
propositions comme faire des pas de
danse à deux ou alors vous danser comme
des feuilles d'arbres
rendez vous le samedi 23 mars à 16
heures à la ferme du mousseau pour
découvrir la performance des élèves et
le vernissage de l'exposition à l'ombre
des forêts casser les stéréotypes montré
par exemple que la danse ce n'est pas
que pour les filles le conservatoire de
plaisir a cueilli un atelier dans ce
père enfant c'était à l'occasion de la
première semaine de l'égalité femmes
hommes de la ville sur place patrick
jacques de dixmude le récit de marylène
yapi chinon ce matin là au conservatoire
de plaisir les enfants font danser leur
papa
moi qui se fait souvent des stages par
enfant la plupart du temps c'est les
mères qui viennent avec leurs enfants et
aujourd'hui on a bien signalé que c'est
un atelier papa enfants la danseuse
chorégraphe venue de poitiers a préparé
toute une série de jeux pour que les
deux opus vivre de vrais moments de
partage artistique
on va pas se mettre à la barre et faire
des exercices dit de danse en fait on
l'affrontera en mouvement de façon
ludique joyeuse dans le jeu ils vont pas
avoir l'impression de se mettre dedans c
est finalement à la fin la séance et
qu'on s'apercevra requis ils sont denses
et qui sont bien dans leur corps en
train de danser avec les corps qu'ils
ont même s'ils ne sont pas danseur à la
base allez on va faire de ce jeu là on
vérifie d entre vous qui est sédentaire
qui est nomade
une matinée qui s'inscrit dans la
semaine pour l'égalité femmes hommes de
la ville de plaisir
histoire de rappeler que les papas aussi
peuvent passer du temps avec leurs
enfants
toute la semaine on est au boulot au
travail et nos enfants font les
activités à côté et donc là c'est un
moment privilégié où je vais pouvoir
voir ce qu'elle fait et puis elle ça lui
plaît aussi de savoir son papa viens et
vois ce qu'elle fait et partager un
moment avec elle c'est vrai qu'à la
maison elle ou lancent souvent pour pour
la campagne qu'on danse avec elle un peu
à la maison donc là c'était l'occasion
de faire ça dans un endroit avec un
cadre avec une professionnelle donc
voilà c'est l'occasion de partager ce
moment ensemble pendant ce un peu à la
maison avec l on fait un peu défaut
fouet puis avec danse avec les stars
on s'y prête donc c'est l'occasion de
faire ça ici avec avec des papas qui
font les fous fous avec leurs petites
filles et petits garçons une matinée
riche en complicité
attention cet atelier père enfant est
réalisé par les amateurs
il est fortement recommandé de le
reproduire chez soi
[Musique]
et puis on l'a tous fait au moins une
fois à porter les vêtements de ses
parents pour faire comme les grands de
se souvenir d'enfance julien caidos on a
fait une exposition visible visible
jusqu'à début avril à la mairie de
guyancourt découverte signe et mélanie
poké après les mots le cliché julien
caïd ans a fait poser des centaines
d'enfants
ce photographe professionnelle leur a
demandé de s'habiller avec un vêtement
d'adultes d'un de leurs parents c'était
une façon de parler du vêtement à
travers le prisme
de l'enfance qui est un prisme de
spontanéité de va dire quelque chose
depuis naturel dehors de mon travail
artistique je suis je suis photographe
professionnel donc je travaille
autour du portrait d' pour les antilles
santé des institutions
je fais de la photographie de mode aussi
j'ai déjà fait des photographies
d'enfants pour des magazines et pour des
catalogues de vêtements donc c'est vrai
que c était un peu l'élément déclencheur
de cette idée julien caloz veux parler
de leurs projections dans l'âge adulte
la construction de leur identité 150
clichés d'enfants guyancourt toit de 6 à
10 ans réalisée dans des écoles de la
ville les enfants ils ont voilà c'est
spontanéité la dent en tout cas quand il
pose devant un objectif qui est quand
même quelque chose de plus facile à a
capté que qu'un adulte voulait pas non
plus quelque chose de trop figée donc
c'est vrai que je les ai pas mal guidé
pour qu' il soit pas toujours de face
qui regardent pas toujours justement
c'était vraiment dans l'idée d'avoir
aussi voilà sept cette mosaïque de
portraits qu'ils soient pas formellement
tous deux face à regarder l'objectif a
pas sourire ou à sourire j'avais j'avais
envie aussi de varier les
les plaisirs on va dire de du cadrage un
projet d'exposition réalisé à trois lors
d'une résidence à guyancourt julien
caidos a travaillé avec deux
psychologues un jeu d'enfant pour faire
comme les grands qui peut donner envie
aux adultes de redevenir petit cette
information transport avant de vous
quitter attention si vous comptiez
emprunter la ligne l du transilien ce
week-end il n'y aura pas de train entre
les gares de montparnasse et de
versailles chantiers trafic interrompu
entre vendredi 22h30 14 heures des
travaux de maintenance seront réalisés
sur le réseau
les lignes de bus régulières entre paris
et versailles seront renforcés en
substitution
la fin du set 8 journal c'est bien sûr à
revoir sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv à 78 dans un
instant le 7-8 loisirs pour être au fait
de toutes les idées de sorties à faire
sur le territoire belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]